It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Bye bye!
Thank you!
Thank you for joining us again!
Especially today, it's our 122nd episode!
BAU BAU!
Good number!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Back to regular schedule!
It feels like it's been forever huh?
There's been so many things going on, so... Thank you, Ruffians, for joining us!
Especially now!
Summer is now officially ended, and now it's time for something new!
Thank you for continuing to join us despite new things going on too!
BAU BAU!
Well, maybe there's some Ruffians who are joining us today for the first time.
Well, to explain FUWAMOCO Morning, it's a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
It's FUWAMOCO.
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Are you happy we're back?
I'm happy, Ruffians.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's been a while, FUWAMOCO Morning!
I'm back!
You're the first FUWAMOCO Morning in a little while!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Wow, you know what?
There's been so many exciting things going on for FUWAMOCO.
Going up?
Going on!
Going on, going on.
So, let's check them out!
Good job!
That's what I like to see.
Well... It's hard to say, but... What's hard to say?
There's been another Pero sighting.
Why?
I haven't seen Pero for a while!
I haven't seen him, that's so useful.
Well, let's see where he was spotted this time.
Okay.
De-den!
Huh?
What the heck?
Why is Pero here?
And Sidewalk Chalk.
I guess, you know, Sidewalk Chalk is a fun summer activity, but it is Pero getting innocent children to draw flattering images, flattering portraits of him.
It does look pretty good here.
What happens to the children afterwards, you know, after they finish the portraits?
Despicable.
I don't know.
I don't know, we can only hope Ruffians maybe they have some leftover pudding on them or... Eat stone.
Pudding.
He likes pudding.
Everyone likes pudding and Sighting and Rock Talk together, right?
Yeah.
The best summer, right?
Right, yeah!
It's not like the children would be hungry and eat the pudding.
No.
Yeah, but this is such a good drawing.
Yeah, right!
He looks very cute, almost.
Very round.
Perfectly round.
I can only think of our poor children.
We have pudding, I'm sure.
I'm sure.
Let's hope children have pudding on them.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Pero's a good baby, so as long as there's pudding, it's alright.
Pudding and pudding.
BAU BAU!
It's for the best, okay?
For the best.
Wow!
Happy new year!
BAU BAU!
Good news, Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO!
We just released our first original song at the beginning of August as part of our first anniversary!
Just about a month ago now!
It's Born to be Balladol!
And it's a very energetic, very FUWAMOCO song.
It's like if you just kind of balled us all up and put us into a song.
Thanks to you!
Born to be Balladol has actually reached over 500,000 views!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Thank you!
You know, it means so so much to us because it's our original song and we're just so happy that you're listening to it live.
That you're enjoying it!
Yeah, and I'm sure you know not just listening to it but singing along, dancing, and most importantly, BAU BAU-ing at the same time too!
A lot of those views are from you.
I'm sure hot.
Thank you.
All 500,000 of them!
Yeah, you know, Balladol, it means so much to us, and it really means the world that you love it so much, Ruffians.
Thank you.
It's really fun!
It's beating your head!
Omochis, you put the sacred book on her head too, apparently.
She kept on being like, Fuwafuwaa.
Mocomoco.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
I don't know about that one, Moco-chan.
Maybe.
BAU BAU in your sleep, baby.
But hopefully, one day, we hope that it can reach 1 million listens here on YouTube soon!
So Ruffians, please make sure you continue to dance along, practice your moves, and BAU BAU together lots with it, okay?
Okay, Ruffians!
Gonna promise.
Yeah!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
B
I'm sure you know that just a little bit more than a week ago, all of hololive English, we were in New York for our second concert, BREAKING DIMENSIONS!
Of course too, FUWAMOCO, we had to perform our original song.
We had to perform BAU BAU there.
We decided this.
Nobody made it.
Yeah, did you see?
Look, Ruffians!
All your fans!
Thank you!
See a pink and blue!
FUWAMOCO colors!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians!
Thank you!
If you missed it, you can check it out on SPWN on Spawn or Streaming.
Also you can get streaming tickets in the archives too.
Or you can also check out there's a bit of a sneak peek over on the hololive English YouTube channel.
And there might be some good things there if you check it out.
Like there's a reason we can show this to you.
You lost your voice!
That's good!
Thank you Ruffians.
It really was a dream come true to us, you know.
Just seeing that- Oh!
The penlights too!
Look at them!
Hearing your big BAU BAU's in person.
You screamed so much!
We'll never forget it!
And we'll keep on waking live for next time!
If there is ever a next time!
Hopefully a next time again!
It's not a given, okay?
We really hope that one day we can stand on an even bigger stage right in front of you!
And we can BAU BAU and have even more fun together, that's true.
Thank you Ruffians!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
You broke into tears the moment the song started up.
Sorry for making you cry right away!
I understand.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Please check it out too!
I think you know FUWAMOCO, we might have lots of fun coming up too.
Yeah!
Maybe we can reveal our breaking dimensions all together.
All together!
And with secret stories.
BAU BAU!
Well, you know, we're in New York.
And then, you know, just this weekend, right after Breaking Dimensions, we were all together with Abyssgard at Anime Impulse in California for a guest appearance.
Look at us there!
We had so so much fun!
I'm just surprised too, you know, we didn't think that we'd get to see the Ruffians so soon after Breaking Dimension.
Yeah.
And we had so much fun.
It was a bit of an early morning, you know.
But we were able to spend so much time together.
It was so much fun.
It was a lot of cute and funny, you know, together.
All together with Advent.
We argued, debated.
Together, not just with Advent, but with you two in the audience.
FUWAMOCO Being able to see your face!
Your voice!
Yeah.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
We hope we can chat even more in the future with hololive Mii, okay?
Just call us, okay?
BAU BAU!
You are so cute.
It's really just so much fun.
I wish we could have been able to do like hololive Mii after breaking the mention there.
Why?
Why did we not do it?
Yeah.
Why?
FUWAMOCO is safe!
FUWAMOCO every corner!
Yeah!
Please!
BAU BAU!
Yeah!
We really wanna go everywhere and anywhere.
Especially if it's close to you, Ruffians.
We wanna go everywhere so we can't say everywhere.
We wanna go!
Follow with you.
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
As you can kinda maybe tell, it's been a bit of a whirlwind of crazy excitement ever since Breaking Dimensions.
But within everything going on, FUWAMOCO, we also released a brand new cover song of the ending theme from the TV anime, Koi wa Futago de Warikirenai.
Love is Indivisible by Twins.
And the song is... Honey Citron!
BAU BAU!
Did you listen?
What'd you think?
What'd you think of this?
A bit, a bit different.
Yeah, it's a bit different from our previous song coverings.
Because this time, we're directly asked to sing it from the anime team!
Official coverings!
That doesn't happen!
Isn't that so cool?
Right!
We're just really really happy because while Futaki was already in anime we were really looking forward to.
And then to suddenly be asked to sing their song!
Right!
It's a really big step, you know?
It's a big deal.
Yeah.
So you know, so we put all, everything, everything, all of our power into the recording of it.
It was like, our only anime song.
It's not though, it's not.
Yeah.
But you know, at the very least, it's an official cover song.
Yeah!
Right?
Official!
Not quite our anime song.
In our heart.
In our heart, in our delusions, right?
Yeah, it's a very very cute song.
Especially, you know, if you like their last cover song, Let Me Be With You.
I think you'll like Honeysuchan a lot too.
Please have a listen.
Also, the illustrations in the video, this illustration right here.
It's illustrated by the original light novel illustrator, Arumiku-sensei!
Right?
It's a huge honor!
Please check it out, okay?
You can't miss it!
Please listen to it lots, and also!
Futakire, the anime, is still airing right now!
You can check it out over on Crunchyroll!
But it's a really interesting love comedy.
Very drama, not really comedy.
Yeah, between twins.
A bit of a love triangle.
So, Ruffians, maybe if you could... I don't know why it's called a comedy.
It's a bit of a love triangle.
If you're curious, maybe what that would be like or maybe what kind of disaster that would be like.
You'll need to check it out, okay?
BAU BAU!
It's a dramedy.
I don't even know about that.
I don't know who called it a comedy.
I think their idea of comedy is different.
Yeah.
There's a lot of silly things going on, that's for sure.
Please check it out, Wolfie!
Take a listen, okay?
BAU BAU BAU!
There's an event going on called ENigmatic Recollection!
Have you been watching Ruffians?
Yeah, have you seen it?
Right now it's in process of a big special brand-wide event, an original content project.
And in it, all of us hololive English members, we are the main characters!
We've sort of lost our memories, huh?
Sort of lost our memories.
The world is the kingdom of lobestos.
And there, the lobestians live!
And you know the world is kind of plagued with stains.
Calamity.
But it's okay because we, all of hololive English, we are there as heroes!
And we'll unlock our memories again!
And we'll save all of lobestos!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Things are getting more and more crazy with everyday eating hot pot.
And we'll do our best, especially with our labestin cloaks.
Very, very special hero cloaks.
But also for En Record!
We're also on the special Watch Party Show!
Did you watch all fans?
Yeah!
We were there this time not singing, but kind of sharing some really exciting information and playing games together with our senpai for the very first time!
Kronii-senpai, Ai-senpai, Ina-senpai, and Kiara-senpai!
Do you forgive her yet, Moco-chan?
I forgive her.
Why don't you forget?
Don't forget.
Please check it out, there's a lot of funny moments, especially, you know, where you're kinda like, I still don't quite get what Unreckle is.
It will probably help you get up to speed a little bit.
You know?
And, well, maybe it's a little bit of spoilers, but FUWAMOCO, we have been sorted into your G-Zord, you know?
FUWAMOCO, I guess you know they're like, FUWAMOCO, you have courage, you have grit.
Sure.
Yeah.
And that's where we are together with mysterious Calli, Elizabeth, and John Watson.
Ami-senpai.
Not John Watson.
And also right now you can also check out the official ENigmatic Recollection!
Enreko!
We call it Enreko for a reason.
The official theme song.
Start again.
Sung by Ai-senpai, Kaori-senpai, Nerissa, and Elizabeth.
It's very... What's the word?
It's very hype, but it's sort of different, huh?
Right?
It's sort of different.
It makes you sort of want to bounce.
Bounce and stomp.
Stomp.
March maybe a little bit.
Am I the only one who wants to bounce and stomp?
Right!
Right, and it's animated as well!
Please go take a look at it!
Also, maybe if you go take a peek at the official hololive store, you'll also notice that there's some very exciting anime merch there too!
You know, if you want to remember this project forever and ever, please go and check it out there on the official hololive show!
Now this is only chapter one, because Enryku is a long-term project.
A long-term project, yeah.
So it'll be going this entire week, the very first week of September here.
So we hope that you'll join us all, all of hololive English, as we continue on our journey in the kingdom of Robusto.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Have you been enjoying it so far?
What do you think?
Oh, you want your own cape?
That's only for heroes, Ruffians.
You want your own cape, bitch?
Are you saying you're not heroes?
Lottery!
I don't know what you're talking about.
It's not a lottery.
You can get the merch without a lottery.
Yeah, not lottery.
Yeah.
hololive means there's a little bit of a lot of it, but... Yeah.
Please go check it out!
Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Well, you know... A new week is here!
A new month is here!
And well, there's a lot of things going on, Moco-chan.
Ruffians, are you feeling okay?
Are you ready for it?
I don't know if the Ruffians are ready.
Oh no, the new month just started.
Ruffians!
It's that time of the week again!
It's time!
Yes!
You know what time it is!
It's time for another Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me!
Mococo!
Ruffians.
Ruffians!
It's a new month!
A new start!
Did you do your best to enjoy the end of summer?
Altered match potential high!
I know, it can be scary having another change, a big new start to your year!
But, sooner than later, it'll feel like your regular everyday once again.
Do your best, but sometimes you need to know that no matter how hard you work, that things won't go your way.
And that's okay.
You know, even if you put 200% in, it shouldn't be just to get a certain result, but to also enjoy the journey together along the way there, okay?
You know, that way, if you don't get the result you wanted, then it's not a huge disappointment, okay?
Because it's just natural that sometimes things won't go as you hope or as you expect.
And that's okay!
Got it!
Let's continue to do our best no matter the result.
And don't forget to have fun along the way, okay?
Ganbatte de!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, are you ready to go?
Don't be scared, okay?
You can do it!
Even if things don't quite work out as you expect them to do.
BAU BAU!
It's been a little while!
Let's see!
What the Doggie of the Day is today?
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
It's Kona and Nao!
Just like us, you know.
Just a little different blue and red, right?
Look at them, they're so fluffy.
I don't know, much fuzzier maybe.
But Kona looks a little concerned right now.
What's Noa up to something, huh?
Maybe, maybe some teasing!
Teasing fun.
Let's give Noa the head pass, huh?
MMC.
Just how Kona bows bows.
On the topic!
How do they bow bow, Moco-chan?
BAU BAU.
They look pretty identical.
The faces look like they did something.
You didn't notice the difference?
I think Noah's up to something.
Check your ears, okay?
Well, you know, I can tell Kona and Nao are best buddies that go everywhere together.
Noah.
Nao.
Yeah.
Maybe they get into trouble and argue sometimes, but
I can tell it doesn't last long.
Kind of like us, right?
Yeah.
They're really good puppies and they're always happy to go for a walk together by your side.
I know I am.
Walks are always good.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for the endless BAU BAU!
Have you been going on walks, Ruffians?
We went on a walk!
I am Central Park.
I don't have a penis.
Hold on, I know I get to go on a walk.
Right.
Well, let's see what you went on a walk with me, Ruffians!
For today's I went on a walk, we have... De-den!
Woah, woah, woah, what is this?
A river?
It's amazing!
Right!
It kind of looks like... Hollow Summoner!
Night pool!
So fancy!
I don't think it's a night pool.
No.
It's just a nice colorful river, right?
It sort of looks like you could have a... ...adventure.
I don't know.
Is that just me?
It's like an adventure.
Yeah!
Right!
That's what I was thinking.
I don't know.
I don't think we're gonna see Marin-senpai and Jo-senpai come out of there in 4K all of a sudden.
No.
No?
It's just, you know, something beautiful to look at at the end of your day, you know?
At the end of the summer time, maybe?
Yeah!
Enjoy it while going on maybe your last summer night still alive.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Welcome to FUWAMOCO!
For our Question of the Day, we have... De-den!
Good day, FUWAMOCO!
Good day!
In Born to be Bound, there's a part where Mococo got silly and changed the song differently than what it was originally.
What was supposed to be in that part of your song?
Team Ruffians!
We both decided, you know, we're gonna sing a very cute, idly, very FUWAMOCO song, right?
Right, you know?
Maybe we're BAU BAU here, we're FUWAFUWA there, and MOCOMOCO there.
But then!
Moco-chan here had different plans.
Had to throw in a heck time, huh?
What's the deal, huh, Moco-chan?
Ruffians!
You love it, right?
Heck time!
Heck yeah!
I guess, Ruffians.
If you like it, then it's good, but... I don't want anyone thinking that we're naughty puppies.
Heck yeah!
We're good demon guard dogs, right?
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much!
Thank you for all your submissions!
You are an important part of FUWAMOCO Morning!
We need you!
So please, send us your demon guard dogs.
Oh my gosh, that's us.
Actually, the Ruffians already do that.
Huh?
You send us screenshots all the time of certain pair of demon-glide dogs.
What?!
Please send us your dogs of the day!
Not your demon-glide dogs!
Please send us your Pero sightings.
Any questions you have!
As loves, please send us the walks.
I wanna know the nice beautiful autumn walks you're gonna be going on.
Please use the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Okay, we're waiting, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
And for our next stream, we have... De-den!
Day 5.
Have an exciting recollection!
And recoll!
There's been a lot going on everyday.
It just seems to heat up more, and new dungeons, new memories discovered.
It troubles.
You never know what's gonna happen in the kingdom of Lobasto, so please join us, okay?
BAU BAU!
And let's take a peek at our schedule this week.
There's a lot of N-Reco going on.
But!
You know, we have the final on Saturday.
Day 8.
The final day of N-Reco.
Yeah!
And then on Sunday we're gonna be watching Day 1 and Day 2.
Both days of Breaking Dimensions.
So Ruffians, if you haven't got your streaming tickets, please get your paws on them and then we can watch it all together!
Okay!
Don't worry if you haven't been able to catch up with the archives for N-Reco 2.
Yeah.
Okay!
Just watch!
Watch them when you can.
When you want to, okay?
There's a lot going on.
A lot.
Thank you, Ruffians!
And for Ruffians who are joining us today through the archives, here is your FUWAMOCO word!
It's BAU BAU BUSY BAU BAUS!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Especially after a little break.
Thank you!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
MEN MEN!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
Bye-bye!